[Música]
soy un ambientalista imperfecto si así
como suena una ambientalista imperfecta
pero antes de contarte mi historia te
quiero preguntar si ha sentido la
presión de querer cambiar el mundo de
ser como personas como gandhi martin
luther king algo
te voy a contar tres conceptos que si lo
aplicas puedes cambiar el mundo
cambiando perspectiva suena muy
romántico lo sé cambiar el mundo pero sí
se puede yo soy tan tan chalita y esta
es mi historia antes de entrar en
detalles te quiero contar un contexto
del tema hacer preguntas como qué está
pasando ambientalmente actualmente
a qué nos estamos enfrentando qué
paradigmas existen del ambientalista a
qué nos estamos enfrentando actualmente
en temas del medio ambiente nos estamos
enfrentando a que tenemos el tiempo
contado que vamos a encontrar el reloj y
si no me crees hay un reloj nueva york
que marca las horas que nos quedan y
dice que quedan ocho años aquí nos
estamos enfrentando no no es a los
corporativos no es al gobierno no es a
las grandes empresas es a nosotros
mismos luchando todos los días por
cambiarnos a nosotros para cambiar al
mundo
que para venir más existen del
ambientalista que el ambientalista tiene
que ser perfecto que tiene que tener un
estilo de vida determinado y eso no es
cierto
entonces tres conceptos ahora si el
primer concepto es medio ambiente soy yo
medio ambiente soy yo qué significa me
encanta cómo empezó esta historia porque
empezó sin siquiera darme cuenta yo me
gradué de la carrera de ingeniería
ambiental tenía toda esta información
que compartir de todo lo que había
aprendido y fue cuando inicié mi blog
y empecé compartiendo datos concretos
pero consistentes como sabías que el
mexicano promedio al año usa más de 2000
kilos de plástico
en méxico se producen más de 21 millones
de botellas de pet al año
entonces yo compartí estos datos y mis
seguidores me hacían preguntas que según
yo no tenían nada que ver con medio
ambiente voltean y me decían oye que te
pones en el pelo y que maquillaje usas y
de donde la blusa que está dispuesta
suceso volteaba hacia de dónde es no me
sabían las respuestas entonces me tengo
que poner a buscarlas y buscando esas
respuestas me di cuenta que gran parte
de los productos que utilizaba dañan el
medio ambiente
entonces fue cuando tuve que hacer algo
al respecto y cuando empecé a buscar
esas respuestas entre más me metía a los
ingredientes a los procesos de
producción a encontrar estas fuentes de
las materias me di cuenta de que todo
viene del medio ambiente
6 porque no nos damos cuenta de esto
porque cuánto nos está pasado que ves tu
pasta de dientes ingredientes ibex cloro
fosfato de sodio
y lo único que piensas es un laboratorio
es un ingrediente laboratorio pero antes
de pasar por esos procesos químicos en
el laboratorio y volverse a su pasta de
dientes
el profesor anxo dio bien en la florita
que es un mineral era una piedra nada
más que eso una piedra pero nosotros no
pensamos en eso aquí es donde entra el
segundo concepto naturaleza transformada
entre más te das cuenta y entre más
investigas todo viene de la naturaleza
absolutamente todo desde un caso del
flor fosfato en una pasta de dientes
mujeres cuántos de nosotros nos damos
maquillaje
uno de los ingredientes principales del
maquillaje es el óxido de titanio puedes
creer que el óxido de titanio es el
noveno elemento más común en la tierra y
también viene de 3 minerales diferentes
una es la nasa el brut y lió entonces
qué son los minerales más piedras tú
usas un maquillaje pero era una piedra
vayámonos de cama la ciencia' vayámonos
algo súper aterrizado muy casual en
nuestra vida que todos lo usamos todos
los días si lo damos por hecho y ni
siquiera nos cuestionamos de dónde viene
la computadora o el teléfono por el cual
estás viendo estate
esta computadora
si lo puedes creer tiene más de 30.000
componentes pero no lo pensamos damos
por hecho que es una computadora pero
esos 30.000 componentes a pesar de ser
30.000 piezas diferentes se reducen más
petróleo plástico
se reducen a vidrio que viene del cuarzo
que normalmente lo extraen de bancos de
arena y metal que también son montañas
al final del día
te puedes imaginar todo lo que tuvo que
pasar la naturaleza esos procesos de
transformación para que llegara a ser
una computadora
es el teclado que tú tienes enfrente de
ti que es plástico hace millones de años
era un fósil y tuvieron que pasar
millones de años para que fuera petróleo
para que lo usemos cuánto cuatro años es
justo
el darte cuenta de esto el volverte una
persona consciente te hace valorar las
cosas entonces tenemos que aprender a
valorar y ver esto porque cuando lo
hacemos podemos consumir menos podemos
consumir mejor y tomar mejores
decisiones
entonces concepto número 1 medio
ambiente soy yo concepto número 2
natural está transformada absolutamente
todo es naturaleza transformada
imagínate que tienes un lente en frente
de ti y pudieras ver las cosas a través
de excelente y vieras de que están
compuestos realmente eso es lo que hago
yo todos los días
el tercer concepto mejora continua
hay un chef que es muy buen amigo que
trabajaba en uno de los mejores
restaurantes del país en mexico y un día
decidió regresarse en su ciudad en
veracruz para poner su propio
restaurante pero como había aprendido
muy bien sabía que la calidad y la
frescura lo es todo entonces decidió ir
con los pescadores a la playa cuando
recién salían del mar a comprarles el
pescado porque sabía que ser el mejor
cuando llegó a la playa con estos
pescadores se dio cuenta la cantidad de
pescados y animales que mataban por unos
pesos el kilo entonces se dio cuenta que
estos pescadores tenían que trabajar
tenían unas familias que mantener tenían
que tener un sustento para su vida pero
algo no se sentía bien del como lo
estaban haciendo ese dios tuvo la
brillante idea
de crear un nuevo modelo les dijo estos
pescadores ok te voy a pagar bien te voy
a pagar esos pesos que tú ganas pero aún
mejor no te los voy a pagar por kilos
pero va a parar por un pescado cada
pescado que saques pero lo tienes que
sacar así entonces creo un modelo de
pesca en el que los pescadores pescan
con gancho de forma selectiva un pescado
a la vez y no sólo una especie el ser
humano puede comer más de 123 especies
entonces en ese lugar de veracruz puede
llegar a sacar hasta 12 o 15 especies
diferentes entonces con gancho selectivo
un pescado a la vez respetando vedas
respetando temporadas sabiendo qué
pescado se puede comer y que no y el que
no se regresa al mar esto creo
y lo logró y ahora eric y yo juntos
logramos que más de 60 familias de
pescadores dejen la pesca masiva y se
vayan a la pesca selectiva y se les
pague comercio justo por esto y al mismo
tiempo logramos que 36 restaurantes
alrededor de la república dejen los
pescados comerciales como el salmón y el
atún que están sobreexplotados y
disfruten la pesca del día esto es
mejora continua es entender que se
pueden hacer mejor las cosas entender
que el ser humano puede vivir en
equilibrio con la naturaleza que si hay
una forma de hacerlo que hay una forma
de ser mejor con tu comunidad con el
medio ambiente y contigo
entonces aquí está la respuesta para ser
un ambientalista imperfecto pero activo
no de teoría activo realmente
medioambiente soy yo
y entender que todas mis decisiones de
todos los días cada una de ellas tiene
un impacto allá afuera y yo tengo la
decisión en mis manos
que todo absolutamente todo es
naturaleza transformada junto a los
lentes a ver una lupa voltea a tu cuarto
a tu casa a tu oficina a donde sea que
estés y voltea a ver las cosas que son
de donde vienen de que están compuestos
ya no veas objetos de naturaleza
transformada y por último mejora
continua
como en la historia del pescador más no
siempre significa que es mejor a veces
es menos pero si existe la posibilidad
de hacer mejor las cosas de ser un
ambientalista consciente de su entorno
de ayudar a tu comunidad y de saber que
puedes hacer el bien viviendo tu vida yo
soy chantal chalita y soy un
ambientalista imperfecto gracias
[Música]